okay
welcome everybody and uh good morning
and welcome to this
latest meeting with the trafford covered
19 public engagement board
uh before we commence um obviously
yesterday was the
anniversary of the first lockdown and i
think it's only appropriate
that we just take a minute to reflect on
the deaths we've had in trafford and the
destination wide
and the losses that people have suffered
during kobe said we'll just take a
moment silence i'll be very grateful
thank you
thank you um item one's a tendency so we
any apologies at all please uh
alex to just counsel accordingly
yes um thank you very much indeed
are there any decorations of interest in
today's agenda items by any member
present
thank you um the minutes of the last
meeting item three
can we take them as read please and are
they approved as an accurate record of
that meeting
i'll take that silence is golden so
we're on to the update in the current
covid 19 situation in trafford
uh a much cheerier picture for us i
think eleanor
uh going forward but still you know
let's not be complacent but i'll pass
over to you now thank you
yes absolutely it is a very very much
better picture than we have been seeing
and we're continuing to see our numbers
come down
um the really good news is that for the
when our rates now are as low as they've
been since early september
last year so we have really seen a
significant decrease
we still have um and the fantastic news
is that we have no
care home outbreaks at the moment and we
have no cases we've had a week
and i don't know if we can keep this but
we really do want to keep this
we've had a week with no cases of people
in people who are over 70.
um so that is a fantastic piece of good
news
we've seen schools going back and we're
delighted that our schools have gone
back and most of our schools have gone
back very
successfully with with little difficulty
we've had good engagement overall with
the lateral flow testing
program in secondary schools with pupils
and we've got many parents
of primary school children also
undertaking the testing and of course
all the staff are
being regularly tested so that is very
very good news
the um and i'm sure helen or kate
who are on the call and donna will talk
about this as well i think the messages
we do want to make sure we give to
people is that the lateral flow tests
are for asymptomatic people only and if
you have any symptoms
you really must go for a pcr test
because the lateral flow test isn't as
accurate
anecdotally we've heard of cases where
people have done an acid
lateral flow test on a symptomatic child
and then it's come back negative and
they've sent them into school and we
would really
say please do not do that because you
could well end up with
that child infecting the class we have
seen a little bit of an increase
in particularly in our older primary
school age population
but our highest rates are still in our
working age population
what we've always seen as well we've
seen quite often our older population
and our primary school population rates
sort of
tagging along each other but we're
really hopeful
with the vaccination program and the
success and uptake of that vaccination
program
that we're going to be able to prevent
that spread and on vaccination i think
my main message is
if you are due your vaccine please go
and take it absolutely take it as soon
as you can
there are plenty of doses particularly
before the end of march so if you are in
categories one to nine that's
over 50 or a carer or a health and
social care worker
and you haven't had your vaccine yet
please do go and take it and if you can
get it done before the end of march
so much the better because as you will
have heard there are vaccine supplies
there should be plenty of supplies even
into april
if you're in that key category group but
it's
um i think it's always better safe than
sorry and go along early
that would be my definite advice so if
you've been worrying about it before if
you're hesitant
have a conversation with your doctor
have a conversation with with the
practice nurse
but please do go and get vaccinated uh
in april we will be doing mainly second
dose vaccines and again that same
message
the vaccine is safe um please do go and
get that second dose it's really
important to bolster your own
um immunity to make sure that immunity
lasts for longer
and to stop the risk of you giving that
the um disease to anyone else so again
really really important for people to
take that second dose it
is a two dose vaccine for a reason and
it will
strengthen your immunity so please do do
that um
other things nigel will talk a lot about
the community engagement and
particularly what we're doing around the
community champions
um and he will also talk and rebecca and
i'm sure nigel as well will be able to
talk
about some of the work we've been doing
in the north and we're really starting
to see
increasing uptake in some of the groups
that were had a lack of confidence in
the vaccine initially
so that is fantastic news we're seeing
our biggest increases
in the in the groups in our black
british population
and um our uh
asian and asian british population so
we're absolutely delighted to see that
and the final thing is that we've got
some more work going on
on self-isolation new guidance on
self-isolation and new support to people
who have to self-isolate
because people will know that shielding
finishes at the end
of march that's because everybody in
that group should now have been
vaccinated so again
if you haven't been please do go um and
the but there is more support available
for people who have to self-isolate
because they or somebody in their
household it has copied
so again some really good pieces of news
you eleanor before i open the questions
can i just ask you there is now some
national debate about whether the
government are going to make it
compulsory
for care home workers to be vaccinated
have you any observations you want to
make on that
so at the moment we we do operate a
system in this country of vaccination
being voluntary
um it is with consent and it's it's up
to individuals
there are some vaccines that um people
who work in the nhs have to take
in order to work to do those jobs so i
can on
you know and there are other
occupational vaccines that people have
to take
so i can understand why people might
want to move to an occupational
vaccination program
i think if that we do do that we will
probably want to look at the nhs
and which roles within the nhs need a
compulsory vaccination
a long time alongside care home staff i
think it would be
if we're going to make any any
occupational requirements
it should really be for the nhs in the
appropriate occupations as well as for
care homes
um so it's not it's not uncommon
for vaccination to be compulsory for
some groups
but i think at the moment unless we need
to have a national directive on that
rather than it would be be by individual
care home
i think it makes it very difficult for
the care home managers and for care home
staff
if they feel that different rules are
being applied to them than to others
so i think it's something for a national
national discussion
and agreement about which occupational
groups would meet those criteria
thank you for that and very clear any
questions at all from anyone for
uh
i don't see any hands and you've got
away scot-free and i think so
um right well we'll we'll then move on
then to the um
the the plan update and we'll start with
donner on mass testing and traffic thank
you donna
thank you chair um just a couple of
points to raise um
as you know as we move towards um a
stage release
around lockdown uh testing and contact
tracing alongside code with safe
behaviors
and alongside improving a vaccination
uptake
is a really important point so so the
testing program will remain
we have just received information that
our
asymptomatic testing offer will be in
place till the end of june
and we'll receive funding for that so
that's a really important step
in in that progress um we
look very clearly obviously at our
testing rates and what we are seeing
chair is we're seeing a reduction
in the pcr test uptake
which is probably not surprising when we
look at the prevalence figures that
elena has shared with us but we are
seeing a significant
increase one of the highest in gm around
our
lateral flow uptake um i've got a bit of
a slide that i could share with you on
this i'm just wondering if you wanted me
just to
share that um what it does
it's a bit complicated what it does is
show the whole range of
our local residents who are being
offered lateral flow
so that includes people in workplaces
our nhs frontline staff our care homes
our adult social care staff and staff
who are visiting care homes
our care homes and supported living
visitors
our extra care and supported living
staff domiciliary carers
personal assistants adult day care
our schools our colleges our
universities
and members of households who
are part of a bubble of school staff and
pupils
and those who obviously come into
contact with our vulnerable residents
on a regular basis so it has really
extended the range chair of asymptomatic
testing
and which i think is why we've seen that
huge increase in lateral flow tests
so i think that's a really positive
thing to uh to
to to um to share with you as eleanor
said
um if any uh our residents do have
symptoms
they need to go for a pcr test and we
still have lots of those
available at our site in trafford
so the three-month extension of the
community testing we'll keep our
asymptomatic testing site which is your
nose based at trappertown hall
but also in order to ensure that our
residents have equal access to lateral
flow testing
we are quite far ahead now in terms of
our community collect model
and just waiting for the supplies of
those and they will be available in four
libraries
and three community centres and the age
uk
stroke carers site and as soon as we get
that information we will start to send
out um
comms to support that we've done the
training of the staff
and they're all ready to go once we get
those available
we still don't have um a full clarity
about where
lateral flow tests will be extended
further apart from those groups that
have identified you
and there's been hints that they may be
made available to members of the public
um in a wider format so as soon as we
get details of that we can share it with
you
thank you thank you john i think this
slide was
was was very very helpful it just shows
the the breadth we've got in terms of of
this testing or
or offering lateral flow testing right
across our community
are there any questions at all for uh
donna from members at all
again i i don't see any hands raised so
can we therefore move on to contact
tracing and outbreak management
um i do know that there is um
a newly published outbreak control plan
for kobe 19 which is approved by the
exec member
for health and well-being yesterday so
perhaps
in talking about this helen or kate
you'd like to to mention that and
possibly share that outbreak control
plan with members
in due course thank you absolutely thank
you chair
um um as you mentioned we have got our
new outbreak control plan
and many of the themes we'd already
implemented in trafford
and the the large um the first main
theme really around it
is the outbreak identification and rapid
response theme
now we've been um implementing this in
trafford for
for some weeks now with the release of
additional information that identifies
postcode coincidence data to us so if we
have
more than two cases identified in a
setting
within a two week period we are
proactively contacting
that setting offering them advice and
support around the covered secure
measures that can be a workplace a
school
it doesn't tend to be schools because
they tend to notify us anyway it's
largely been workplaces
and we'll contact that workplace we'll
offer them lots of proactive advice and
in a couple of instances we've actually
found that they've had more cases
than we've been made aware of so we've
been able to step in with some
outbreak management support to them so
it's been very successful
we've currently got um three outbreaks
within workplaces that we're supporting
in trafford
we're hoping to close one of them this
afternoon and
in the school sector and as elena
mentioned the schools have gone back and
it's been
a really successful reintroduction we've
currently got
seven primary schools ten secondary
schools and three early years settings
with cases
and just a note of success around that
asymptomatic testing
of the secondary schools there have been
seven
pupils detected through the asymptomatic
testing programme
that have been isolated um
very swiftly and prevented ongoing
transmission within that school setting
so it has been very successful because
we wouldn't have known about those cases
otherwise
and and i think those numbers given the
numbers of schools and the numbers of
pupils we've got
are really a success story at the moment
and will continue to support our school
settings
the other main um development we've got
coming to to
us is around our our level two contact
tracing which as you know with the
contacts
um the cases that we contact that the
national track and trace team haven't
been able to reach
and were part of a greater manchester
early adopter
for movement to a new contact tracing
system
so we're moving away from the initial
contact racing system
and that's going to give us the capacity
within trafford to target our contact
chasing
much more and discreetly and and
we can review data and and identify
our areas where we may be seeing spikes
in cases
and prioritize different groups
accordingly so that's a really positive
step and we're expecting that to come
online
in april
thank you kate are there any questions
at all for kate
i don't see any hands at all not a
question but just to
add um about the outbreak management
plan so we've sent
we revised the whole of our outbreak
management plan it's gone into public
health england for review
and we'll then get it back and then
it'll go on the council website
um but everything that's in it is stuff
that's already ongoing work that we were
we were doing but it means that the
previous version which we did in june
last year
will has been updated and has all the
current activity and
although things move so fast that it's
probably slightly out of date already
isn't it um
from the stuff that kate was talking
about so we may add a little bit before
it goes on the website
but um i'm hoping that people you know
i'm hoping that members of public will
also find it a useful document
for my part ellen i reviewed it this
morning because i received it first
thing this morning and it is very
thorough
um are you saying we won't be able to
circulate until after it's come back
from public health england i think we i
think we can circulate it because it's
been through our governance system so
there's no no reason not to i think it
was just
it i mean we can put it on the website
now if if we get significant feedback
from public health england we could just
then we would
replace it so whatever you think is more
helpful i would like to see on the
website and i'd like to see it
circulated to all members of this group
uh as soon as thank you very much we can
do that
thank you right
we'll move on then to mass vaccination
in trafford in our bike
invite rebecca uh to speak to us on this
rebecca good morning
thank you chair good morning everybody
um thanks for having me this week
um ellen has covered a couple of the
things that i wanted to update on um but
just
in terms of the current position um this
week
we have um plenty full stock of both
astrazeneca first doses and pfizer
second doses
um and the majority of our primary care
networks are
um using the particular pfizer to
support the
second dose for care home staff and
residents and housebound patients as
well as those that were booked in for
their
um first dose elena briefly mentioned
we're not seeing
quite the same level of uptake or demand
for second doses
um anecdotal feedback is due to either
um people have um having significant
side effects from the first dose and
that's putting them off or
um some element of complacency because
the
um national position is that first dose
obviously effectiveness and efficacy is
very good
so we've done some very targeted um
local comms around the importance of
second dose
uh you will have seen from the national
press that there is then
a national shortage particularly of
astrazeneca first dose from next monday
the etihad mass vaccination center will
be close to bookings from the first of
april because of that supply issue
and we are being told still that there
will be no weeks where we have
no supply in april but those supplies
will be
um much lower than they have been but
the fisa
and supply for second doses will be um
as per current levels
and so it allows the time to make sure
that the second dose he's caught up with
um however the message very much is for
any of that
astrazeneca it's absolutely there to
ensure maximum
uptake in cohorts one to nine and the
contract with the gps to still not allow
um expansion into cohorts 10 to 12.
um cohorts 10 to 12 are included in
phase 2
and primary care networks are being
asked to sign up to a new
enhanced service specification to
deliver phase 2 for 10 to 12.
so absolutely the message is where we've
got astrazeneca in stock
support local mutual aid support system
mutual aid and ensure that we've got
maximum uptake um
in one to nine um so
that's where we're up to at the moment i
think um nigel is on the call so we'll
provide
further update on um the activity that's
happened in the north of the borough
and i know there was some good feedback
from the clinics over the weekend
and latest data shows that within a um a
five-week period the number of vaccines
complete
um week of the 17th of february in the
north
it was 5 382 and five weeks later that
had increased to 11
801 so we are seeing the impact
of um the activity on the uptake rates
in the borough which is um
excellent news so i'll pause there
uh thank you rebecca can i just just ask
um in relation to
second vaccinations that am i right in
thinking it matters not
uh which which vaccination you've got
depend
so if you had it if you had astrazeneca
first time right you could have fires a
second time
so the current standing operating
procedure
and the um the documents that any
professional administering the vaccine
have
not yet been updated to cover a mix
of pfizer first astrazeneca second or
the other way around however we are
expecting that guidance to be issued um
shortly and trials have gone on at the
moment and we are aware that some
um some of our primary care networks
have done
a mixed dose based on their kind of
clinical um assessment so it's not
yet within the guidance but we're
anticipating that quite soon so it's not
it's not um current practice on the
whole but there are
odd indications of that yeah the the
only reason i ask is because it could
that be a contribution where somebody's
maybe had estrogenic the first time
around
and doesn't want fires or vice versa
they want the same vaccination
yeah but i think we're sticking to the
plan mainly of
the first o's second dose is the same
and we're trying very hard not to
introduce choice
uh because that's not the position and
that's not the guidance so it's not you
know you can have which one you want so
we're having to manage that quite
carefully so that's not the message that
we're promoting but
yeah thank you i think that's been very
clear and very helpful any questions at
all for rebecca
from members yes george
yeah i suppose it's more of a comment
than a question mike but i just think
that significant increase that we've
seen in the north in terms of uptake
really demonstrates how
people have managed to come together to
work you know through public health
primary care and the engagement team to
engage
residents in the area in the way in
which we've consistently talked about in
this meeting by
you know getting out on the streets
getting messages that people understand
and just
you know i think it's really important
for us to recognize that success
and learn because that's how we're going
to manage inequality as we're moving
forward
i think you're absolutely right there
george and thank you for raising that
point
um nothing further i can't see any hands
raised so shall we therefore move on to
uh
to uh nigel is going to talk to us about
uh escalations from the community
engagement team and
can you particularly uh make reference
to champions in the north of the borough
which is a point raised by council
corridor who can't be with us today
nigel
councillor freeman yes so in terms of an
update from the community engagement
work the first thing i just wanted to
mention
um was around the vaccination clinics
in the north uh as rebecca mentioned we
had some really good success there
uh the last few weeks so the uh the
community engagement team and ccg
colleagues have been
continuing to support the volunteer
offer at the clinics
and i really wanted to highlight the in
particular the two successful
clinics that we had at the limelight
health and wellbeing hub on saturday
so the local gp practice welcomed over
170 patients through their morning
clinic
on saturday so this was the second
weekend in a row where
vaccinations were available to local
residents who were over 50.
uh alongside the community engagement
team there were volunteers from
limelight the voice of bme lmcp and the
british red cross who kind of welcomed
patients
to their uh to the clinic um
and what happened as well this this
saturday we
the first initial clinic was followed by
a clinic
for uh that was arranged by a local
mosque for
again for over 50s the mosque had
partnered up with a local pharmacy
and this was their first vaccination
clinic in trafford so
this clinic was approved by nhs england
and
uh the limelight staff there provided
you know what was really a
kind of perfect setting there for
members of the mosque to come
and attend and have the vaccination
after after prayers
and the mosque chairman has confirmed
afterwards that around 50 people
attended and were able to receive their
first vaccine
so um this this was coordinated
by the traffic housing trust volunteer
coordinator there who oversaw the
operation the day made the transition
between the two clinics work you know
really seamlessly
uh we supported it from the community
engagement team eleanor
attended as well to offer her support
and a lot of this was made possible by
work
and from colleagues from the ccg a very
short notice to make this possible so
it's a really really good example
of um great work by the community groups
volunteers the faith groups they're all
coming together and supported by council
and ccg colleagues so
both clinics really well attended lots
of support from the local community
as has been highlighted by the positive
response and
as eleanor said we just really want to
encourage everyone else who is
eligible to have their vaccine to take
up as soon as they can
in terms of uh vaccine
vaccination confidence another really
good news story is to mention the work
that we've been doing in conjunction
with voice of bme
and they're making really good progress
in uh reducing vaccine hesitancy
so they're positioned within the
practices in the north
and uh staff they're very experienced
have been trained by the public health
team to make calls to patients what they
do is they talk and listen to patients
about their thoughts and concerns
provide them with facts and reassurance
about the vaccine and how any support
they need
and then if patients are happy to do so
they'll then book an appointment for
them
you know if they've changed their mind
and now decided to go ahead and have the
vaccine so
they've been doing this work for around
a month now and the number of patients
have decided to take the vaccine so i
think in their first
two weeks um they were able to uh
book appointments for 38 people that
were initially hesitant but then decided
to to go ahead with a vaccine
so since then they've been doing this
for about another two two weeks or more
so we're just waiting for the latest
figures from them
uh but that was really really good news
that initial 38 people in the first two
weeks of their work
and they're going to be giving us kind
of updates on a weekly basis now on the
success that they're having
in terms of other work in the north the
team will be focusing
on uh this week on finalizing plans for
a program of door knocking which we're
going to be piloting piloting in old
trafford
so this is going to build on the
one-to-one approach through the phone
calls with voice of bme and the aim is
to speak to
individual households in the area in
areas as led by the data
where we'll promote the local clinics
listen to people's concerns
provide reassurance and then link back
to calls
if people want them through a voice of
pme
another issue that we're looking at is
vaccination in
homelessness and rough sleeping so this
is something that we're picking up and
having a look at and we're looking at
different options speaking to colleagues
at host
and also said john's ambulance to look
at a potential solution
in terms of the community community
champions program the team are working
through an action plan
we've been learning from best practice
from other local authorities both in
great manchester
and nationally uh the website and
information will soon be launched uh
with uh comms to highlight the aims and
opportunities available
and champions will be able to sign up
we'll be giving them the latest
information on covid 19 which on
a weekly basis which they can then share
with
their contacts in the community and
we're providing champions with regular
information sessions
and check-ins with the public health
team and the community engagement team
in terms of the team itself just a bit
of an update on our recruitment so i
think i mentioned to you last time
that we had recruited to four
neighborhood engagement officer posts on
temporary contracts
for six months so the good news is we've
got the first two of those new members
of staff starting with us next week
and hopefully the two should be starting
with us soon afterwards so that'll
really help us with our capacity
as we start to come out of lockdown to
be able to do more engraved
engagement on the ground and we're also
looking to recruit to a new volunteer
officer that's going out to advert and
we'll be
interviewing in april excuse me and uh
this officer will be responsible for
administration and coordination of the
day-to-day aspects of volunteer
management related to cobit 19
and it will just help us with help us
and enhance the volunteer offer that we
have to vaccination clinics
and we want this person to also help and
support with the community champions
support offer and just one of the final
point i want to raise
around is the support that we want to
give to volunteer coordinators
and uh and the hubs where we want
we are looking to get uh volunteer
coordinators that have been working at
the vaccination clinics and also the hub
leads to come together and meet
regularly
so the aim of this will be to offer a
forum for the coordinators to kind of
share good practice
get updates discuss challenges and
feedback or just a kind of supportive
network
for everyone and uh just to
give highlight the role contribution to
volunteers making up
in our communities and uh to offer
further support and coordination for
this important
this important work that everyone's
doing in the vaccination clinics that's
something else that we're looking to put
in place within the next
week or two so that was it in terms of
late for me chair thank you
thanks nigel and can i just thank khan
for his comments in the chat the clinics
in the north trafford have been greatly
appreciated by the local population
i think the work you've evidenced there
that has been going on
is really really good news for the
borough and good news
for all of the communities in that area
as well are there any questions at all
for nigel from
members present
i don't see any hands raised at all
at all so if we can move on to
escalations from
the community enforcement group i didn't
see helen on the call
um am i right is alex is hella not on
the call
um well on that
on the actual subject i do know uh
that obviously the work continues in
terms of the um
advisement given to businesses and
everything else it turns
my my big concern and i i've probably
said this to eleanor before
is that the earliest date for um uh
licensed premises reopening in terms of
of outdoor services to 12th avenue that
is an
early date but there's huge expectation
around that
and for me um the fear is
if that date isn't met uh it's about how
we message and how we how we
manage our community's expectations
around
the process of lockdown easing easing
and the problems this may cause is
because i do know that there are
restaurants
and pubs taking bookings right left and
center from the 12th of april
every intention of opening and and yet
you know there's no room for complacency
in terms of
getting the infection rates down um so i
think this is a major piece of work for
us
and and for this group going forward in
the sort of messaging
that we need to get out to our
communities
to manage their expectations and i'm
quite happy to to throw that open for
debate if anyone wants to
to to come in on that thank you
i i think you're completely right and i
think the key and i think maybe we'll
bring ellie in on
on the comms i mean these dates are no
sooner than dates
they're not set in stone um in
trafford we're doing really well with
getting our rates down
but that's just um when we talk about
our rates obviously we're talking about
our rates in our traffic residents
we have lots and lots of people coming
into the borough for work
absolutely you know and so it really is
making sure
that all our businesses take this very
seriously that all of our residents who
go
um and work outside our borough also are
aware
that you know the risk is even in
traffic the risk is not zero
we still have a significant risk of
covid um we still have cases
spread across the borough as we have
done throughout so it is
um it i think it is very much that we
need to be remembering
these dates are to an extent in our own
hands and we need to make sure that we
are all complying with restrictions
to get the rates down and to get the
rates down across greater manchester
because we absolutely are dependent on
the rest of greater manchester and the
rest of greater manchester is dependent
on
us so i think our main messaging now is
it's it's only a few weeks but please do
everything you can
because we we do know we've still got
cases we know that because
as kate says we're picking some of these
these cases up in our school population
through that asymptomatic testing in
particular so
we there is there is covet out there and
we need to be
really aware of it because if we don't
if we don't all
really try to stick to the rules quite
strictly now
we could put ourselves back in jeopardy
and i think none of us want to be in the
situation
again that we were in in september where
we were having
you know arguments up and down with with
um with our residents with government
about which tier should be we be in and
i i feel myself that the
being able to stay in that national
approach and it is that all we're all in
it together
is really a much more helpful way of
thinking about things and we
we all need to respond to this um and
take it seriously for these next few
weeks while we get the rates down
um ellie i don't know whether um because
i do know that greater manchester rates
and some of our other boroughs
are causing some concerns nationally um
so it absolutely is imperative that we
do everything we can
to stick with the rules because we know
that these rules do work this is what's
brought the rates down
elliott you want to talk about that yeah
we're obviously um
three weeks off um sort of the first
sectors
um reopening but we working on and this
week essentially the message is
mainly to businesses saying prepare now
start putting some
and your cover secure measures back in
place you know there'll be many
businesses who've been closed for months
and so it's more about being proactive
about being positive
we've had the high streets reopening
funding so um
our town centres will have a lot of
signage very encouraging
we want people to stay local obviously
we want people to support local business
but to do it safely
and so as ellen says it's it's about you
know businesses doing it right and then
people
um using our local businesses
responsibly so
um in the next week or so you'll start
to see um messages around
we're really pleased to see things
reopening you know we're pleased to see
people being able to start returning to
normal
but that does need to come with cautious
behavior
and because as ellen says we don't want
to go backwards we certainly don't want
to see anything
any of the work that's been done being
undone
and so we are going to start with that
and as i said hopefully people will see
um in the coming weeks the sort of town
centres will start to look different
and with various signage and just to
remind people
about using shops restaurants whatever
it is
and responsibly also as you know council
freeman you know
nobody wants to enforce the rules
enforcement is absolutely the last
um resort and we really want to
encourage businesses to come back and to
come back well
and safely and the environmental health
team have got offers
of support there and again you know
the work that kate mentioned there is a
lot of support there for businesses
and you know who may find that they need
some support with them with reopening
so yeah over the next couple of weeks
it's mainly about people preparing
themselves
and for the reopening and you know
there's a lot of support there if people
want it we don't want to get to a point
where people
have opened and safely and then you know
we don't want to go down the enforcement
route at all but obviously
it's about you know public health and
public safety so
thanks ellie and i do agree with you i
know we are on the front foot because i
do know we've already written out to all
of our licensed premises
asking them what their intentions are
for the 12th of april onwards
and offering them the guidance and
support that they will need to ensure
that they are going to open
they do it in a safe manner but my
concern is of clearly is if the national
government
roll back on that date it's how we
manage expectations
um you know and and and that has got to
be a concern so
you know for me it's about saying to
people this is the earliest date you
know it's not set in stone
um and hopefully but as i say
the expectation is there it's how we
manage it
but i knew and there is some very good
work going on and
again i pay tribute to the environmental
health teams the rotary services teams
and the public public health teams that
are all working together
uh to to riders of this awful virus
so so thank you um
just moving on i've got a late question
in the in the chat from uh
from councillor new grocer and i've
already kind of bring rebecca back in
we're going to talk about the same issue
i raised with rebecca about
if you have one job clean you have a
different job uh over to you rebecca
thank you chair so um in terms of the
answer that question when
i mentioned that there is a national
standard operating procedure and patient
group direction about to be issued
um in terms of mixing of the vaccine and
that will absolutely include the need
for
consent to a different vaccine at the
point of um delivery
for those few individuals who have been
offered a change in vaccine today and it
really is
um a very small number um the consent
question is asked at the point of
delivery and is captured on the um
patient administration system that's
used to capture the the vaccine um
activity so it would not there would not
be a case of
you you haven't been you know you are
not informed prior or ask your consent
to get two different vaccines
essentially
so that's the question julian
i think that is so that um going forward
there's going to be some form
in the consent where it's understood
that it could be a mix
but for those that have had the vaccine
there isn't that isn't an issue they
will be gaining the second vaccine
because they've consented to that and
can i clear that up so currently without
the national stop there's just been a
few individuals who have had
a different dose of the second vaccine
and at the point of administration of
that second dose
consent for that change in second dose
has been um
confirmed at the point of delivery of
the vaccine on the patient
administration system
yep thank you make sense no worries
thank you
thank you reckon thanks answer the
question julian and thanks for clearing
that up rebecca again
um
i'm going to move on just to we seem to
have skated through the meeting today
uh can i just say that i think this
forum has been very very effective for
us in getting our message out
as you all know the council will enter
election purdue from the 29th
of march a decision has been taken that
this meeting is going to continue
uh it is going to continue under the
chairmanship of the chair of eleanor
and all the vcsc groups will be welcome
to attend
uh councillors will not be attending
this meeting until after
uh the elections uh on the 6th of may
however if councillors do require
an update this can be provided to them
from the chair of the the new chair of
the meeting for the interim period which
will be eleanor
um so um unless there's any further
business
that is the process we're going to to uh
to have going forward i wish you
uh all the best in the next few weeks
eleanor um
and everyone else can i just thank
everybody for the very
very hard work that has gone on here in
ensuring that we've got our infection
rates down that our vaccination program
is rolling out
and that our businesses are getting the
advice um
and we on the work that has contributed
to making trafford a safer place
so um unless there's anything further
from anybody can i thank you for that
and i will hopefully see you
um at a meeting after the elections
thank you very much and can i thank all
of our thank um the chair
and all of the councillors everybody
who's been in the meeting has been it
has been really good
but i really want to thank all of our
residents who have been taking the
restrictions so seriously
it has been a tremendously difficult
time for everyone and i think
particularly
particularly for people our younger
population our children and
our younger working age you know people
in their 20s and 30s
who have had to make tremendous
sacrifices throughout so massive thank
you and it's just please please
keep with it keep going we we are
getting there but we just need to be
very careful over the next few weeks and
councilor lloyd i think had something to
add
you're on mute judith
just thank you very much for keeping me
out and obviously i won't be able to
attend but i would like to be
kept informed so i'm pleased about that
and just to say congratulations really
because i think the vaccination has been
the success
and traffic and where it hasn't been as
good you've
attacked that um so um you know let's
hope
and pray that um we continue to have low
numbers
yeah and i'm going to have my second
vaccine sooner
thank you everybody thanks for your
attendance oh george do you want to come
in no no no
thank you thank you everyone
bye